jonas geht hier ist euer max und heute
gibt es mal wieder ein video nachdem
mein pc endlich wieder funktioniert ich
habe auf twitter gefragt was ihr so
sehen wollte okay das waren zwei
vorschläge aber viele haben auch
geschrieben dass ich was mit justin
aufnehme hier ist der gute herr wurde
ich habe justin gesagt leute daran
merkte schon dass wir ein bisschen außer
übung sind dennis ich natürlich gehört
fallin empfehlen drehen
also werde ich eigentlich auch spiel er
viele haben ja gefragt was los bei euch
habt ihr bis sonstwas warum wir nicht
miteinander aufnimmt
die sache ist einfach wenn ihr
sommerferien zumindest bei mir das heute
morgen habe jeder schule
ich habe seit einer woche wieder spielen
und deshalb haben wir waren einfach viel
unterwegs also ich war auf jeden fall
viel unterwegs
du warst aber auch mal eine zeit lang
urlaub und das war genau die zeit wo ich
sah wie viele 10 09
kommt es hier schnell schnell 20 es
kommt eine r
es ist ein eher mauer wie ihn sehr gut
ich habe lediglich drei gold gemacht und
so und jetzt eigentlich müsste ich mich
umbringen aber die abwässer wo ich mich
gerade hin bauen
ich glaube ich mache etwas kann ich
ihnen damit tun wir hatten uns echt mal
überlegt weil wir nehmen ja das prinzip
eigentlich nur was ich will dann werde
überlegt dass wir alle folgen just 5
macht vereint auf jeden fall endlich mal
wieder was mit justin zusammen
das macht nicht ziemlich das macht mich
ungelogen ziemlich geil
anders als logo auf die kritik von
großen youtuber nein weil ich mich damit
aber wie ich wollt ich hab ja es ist
spitzenjobs in diesem verein
wir hoffen dass jetzt wieder
es ist natürlich ein schwerer konflikt
denn ich ihn mir austragen muss macht
ich verstehe nicht dass er in dieser
hilfe ich bin bei rot ich habe ihn fast
tot
doch es könnte mit einem gewissen bogen
aber die höchster von appen bogen vom
breiten okay jetzt haben wir nur noch
tempo gemacht
wir haben nur noch einen gegner gegen
die top-10 geworfen wie kann jemand
gegner sein
ach so was sich viele auch gefragt haben
wann kommen die blogs aber ich habe die
bereits gefällt hergestellt sie gingen
ich würde dank zehn leute oder t silber
und gleich wieder eine runde
ich glaube es schon so leute hier sind
wieder hier vereint toren kann ich
zusammen rum
auf einer karte die man schon bisher gut
kennen ja weiß ist unser zweiter
lieblings mit ja und hier haben wir auch
den einen oder anderen hat er nicht
gesagt ich weiß jetzt nicht ausdrücken
soll
aber ich würde lieber mit euch zusammen
arbeiten die beats wie den kollegen oder
nein jetzt haben wir im video darüber
geredet jetzt kannst du einen schön
quälen mich wirklich leute wir
parodieren platte ein vielleicht wisst
ihr wer eine person dass wir nur noch
über möchten
ich hoffe ich habe gerade voll verpackt
dass ich das pferd nicht obwohl ich
hoffe ich hoffe auch in minecraft nur
ich kotze gleich wenn ich es schaffe die
abbauen kann
ich bin dafür ich hoffe ich muss dann
auf dem schmiden justin rotz auf meine
schmiedel und gehofft aber es klingt so
sehr wie unwohl
ich war es bei unwohl und der hat mir
seine geilen tactics verraten wie er
sich egal wie schnitzel baut wie hat er
es geschafft ich muss da dein herz
muster aufgelöst als würde ich unterhalt
von jemanden bekommen der mit
ausgeprägten ausgeübt
ich habe mich von ihm getrennt er kenne
ich gut gepasst
doch dann muss der unterhalt zahlen sein
gehalt war höher als meins ist war nicht
obwohl kleine tag etwa nicht obwohl ich
verstehe nichts verändern tag gewesen
kann es seien etwa repower von den
markus land russland beginnen jeweils
bei markit land über die
unzulänglichkeiten seines am umfang
einstudieren
aber von wem schlief und meinen kollegen
wer ist der kollege ich habe den
kollegen der schmerz kollege von dem was
der kollege als einer der ist
kollegialer kollegen ja klar deshalb
heißt der report summe ich bin ein sehr
guter ja klar ich hoffe euch gefällt das
ist just feind sehen das provokant sind
wie eh und je
verändert euch nicht für jemand anders
werden
für obwohl kann man sich verändern
obwohl kann ich auch aufgesetzte
verzichten
die attacke leuten dann sagen